good morning believe nation today's
message is talent can only take you so
far over to you Rory McIlroy TV I always
believed that natural talent can can
take you so far but I think you need to
have the work ethic and the drive to to
achieve your potential I mean I'd say
you know my natural talent you'll
probably brought me fifty percent of the
way but then after that it was all it
was all done to the work that I've done
and the volume of work that I've done
over the you know the last 15 years you
know when I really started to take golf
seriously and you know follow Boyd
you're making this a career I'm end up
with a Toronto entrepreneur who's had a
lot of success with businesses building
them to rapid growth and then selling
them and building new ones up and one of
his favorite expressions that really
stuck with me is that ignorance on fire
is better than talent on ice and the
thought behind that is whatever you want
to learn whatever you want to get into
if you're passionate about it you can
develop any talent any skill where if
you are talented but you're not putting
in the hard work you're not going to
make it the world belongs not to the
talented there's tons of people who have
talent who don't do anything with it
there will belong to the doers the world
belongs to the people who get up every
single day and go to work holding their
craft getting better trying to make a
positive impact that's what the world
belongs to I haven't told the story in a
while I think it's worth for visiting
when I started at the agency that I'm
asked I'm an agent he's in New York he
helps book me into speaking gigs and
book deals and corporate brands when I
first got in touch with him he has to
look at my youtube channel and he looked
at and he said Evan I really like your
content you're talking about some good
stuff but you're on camera presence
really sucks you know it's not good I
don't know if we're going to be able to
do something with you and first that
hurt because I already done hundreds of
videos and I thought I was pretty good
hi I'm Evan karma
welcome to other dejame all in the
Masters I believe that the fastest the
most effective way to grow a business is
to model the strategies of people who
have already done what you're trying to
do hi I'm Evan kind of my coat welcome
to another edition of ask Evan but I
obviously wasn't up to a certain level
standard didn't have that talent or
skill and luckily he said you know what
I see something in you let's take a risk
and he brought me on and he worked with
me to help me get better and every day
he gave me assignments and I worked at
it and I got better right he asked me to
make a video about my story and they
wanted to be on a 30 minute long video
and I did that video i would say at
least 20 * right I would make a new
version he'd say that's not good do it
like this and I'd make a new version and
a new version a new version over and
over and over and over again and I
increased the quantity of work that I
put out right if you look at my youtube
channel i was making one video a day and
then i moved to two videos a day now
three videos a day and the people who
had the agency saw the massive growth in
in me in me getting better and i went in
a couple of months from being the worst
in the agency to being the best practice
example to the point where my agent was
sharing it with his other clients at the
agency saying look what Evans doing
maybe you should be doing something
similar from the worst from the guy who
almost wasn't accepted in right the guy
who didn't have enough talent to almost
I think couldn't get in to now being the
best at the agency and it's because I
listened to feedback but I put in the
insane amount of work where most people
like that agency the clients struggled
to find the time right find the time to
come up with one video a week on their
channel mih is like pulling teeth like
come on you got to get another video up
so we can work to get better they can't
find the time to do one video a week and
I'm doing one two three a day don't you
think I'm going to get better right I'm
going to develop the skills way faster
than these other people because I'm put
it in the effort because I made it a
priority because I made it important so
there's anything that you want to learn
any skill can be overcome just through
practice and dedication and hard work
take the same approach that I did right
go all in on it practice get better
block out chunks in your calendar to
dedicate to doing this so that you'll
rapidly get better because
Thailand is not the variable because you
could pick up the town you could pick up
the skill when you are passionate about
it and put in the work believe so my
question is if you guys today is I'm
really curious to find out what did you
start off in totally sucking at having
no skills no talent but put in the work
and got better at I'd love for you to
share your story in the comments below I
think it could really help inspire other
people who are doubting themselves are
going through similar issues so thank
you guys for watching have an amazing
day continue to believe and i'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
events best